FIRST, BITE AND TURNS ON THE
TROOPS AND THAT’S THE FOCUS OF
TONIGHT’S "ANGLE"."
THE LEFT NOW DOMINATED THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, HEY, JUST
ABOUT EVERYTHING ASSOCIATED WITH
AMERICAN TRADITION FROM FLAKES,
TO MONUMENTS, TO EVEN
CHRISTIANITY.
WHICH IS WHY IT WAS BARELY
IRONIC THAT JOE BIDEN SHOULD
COMMUNICATE HIS LATEST
IDEOLOGICAL PURGE DURING AN
APPEARANCE AT THE NATIONAL
PRAYER BREAKFAST.
>> WE JUST HAVE TO OPEN OUR EYES
EYES.
JUST WITNESS IMAGES THAT WE
NEVER IMAGINED.
IMAGES THAT WILL NOW WE WILL
NEVER FORGET.
THE VIOLENT ASSAULT OF THE U.S.
CAPITOL, THE ASSAULT ON OUR
DEMOCRACY, ON OUR CAPITOL.
A VIOLENT ATTACK THAT THREATENED
LIVES AND TOOK LIVES.
WE KNOW NOW WE MUST CONFRONT AND
DEFEAT POLITICAL EXTREMISM.
WHITE SUPREMACY, AND DOMESTIC
TERRORISM.
>> Laura: USING THE
CAPITOL HILL RIOTS AS A
JUSTIFICATION, I KNOW IT’S ONLY
A MATTER OF TIME UNTIL BIDEN AND
IN SOME ILLUSTRATION WILL TURN
THEIR SITE IN THE U.S. MILITARY.
BIDEN’S PENTAGON CHIEF ANNOUNCED
AND WE MENTIONED IT BRIEFLY LAST
NIGHT, A STAND-DOWN OF ALL U.S.
MILITARY FORCES IN ORDER TO
SCOUR THE RANKS.
THE NEW SECRETARY OF DEFENSE
ISSUED AN IMPOSSIBLE PURGE
DURING HIS CONVERSATION HERE IN.
>> I WILL FIGHT HARD TO STAMP
OUT SEXUAL ASSAULT AND RID ARE
RANKS OF RACISTS AND EXTREMISTS.
THE JOB OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE IS TO TAKE DEMAND KEEP
AMERICA SAFE OF OUR ENEMIES BUT
WE CAN’T DO IT IF SOME OF THE
ENEMIES LIE WITHIN OUR OWN
RIGHTS.
>> Laura: WHAT HE MEANS THERE,
AND WOULD LIKE TO DO NOW IS READ
THE A MILITARY OF ALL STRONG
CONSERVATIVES AND TRUMP
SUPPORTER’S.
THINK OF ALL THE CHALLENGES
AMERICA IS FACING AT THE MOMENT
WITH THE RISE OF CHINA
SPECIALLY.
AND THIS IS WHAT THE DEFENSE
CHIEF IS FOCUSING ON?
NOW, REPORTING THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION DOESN’T HAVE A
PLAN FOR HOW TO CONDUCT ITS
SO-CALLED REVIEW, OR WHAT THE
SAND DOWN WOULD EVEN MEAN OR
LOOK LIKE.
BUT ONE THING IS FOR SURE, IF
THIS IS SUBSTANTIVE, NOT
SYMBOLIC, IT WILL DO GRAVE
DAMAGE TO PREPAREDNESS AND
MORALE.
OUR MEN AND WOMEN IN UNIFORM HAS
BEEN ASKED TO SACRIFICE MULTIPLE
TOURS, MANY OF THEM, FOR SO
LONG.
OFTENTIMES, RIDICULOUS
ENGAGEMENTS, IDIOTIC WARS.
NOW THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
REWARDS THEM BY CASTING THEM AS
POTENTIAL DOMESTIC TERRORISTS?
TICKING TIME BOMBS OF WHITE
SUPREMACY?
YOU CAN ALWAYS COUNT ON
THINK TANK GENERALS WHOSE
SALARIES ARE FUNDED BY RICH
DONORS TO SIGN WITH THE
DEMOCRATS ON THE ISSUE LIKE THIS
THIS.
LIKE THOMAS CLOSETS, A RETIRED
ARMY BRIGADIER GENERAL WHO TOLD
"FORTUNE" MAGAZINE HE’S REALLY W
ABOUT THE ENEMY WITHIN.
SAYING WE ARE PROBABLY TALKING
ABOUT THOUSANDS ACROSS THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE.
MANY OF THEM WILL HAVE ALREADY
RUN THEIR MOUTHS, PUT THINGS ON
SOCIAL MEDIA.
NOW, PEOPLE LIKE HIM WILL CLAIM
THAT IT’S FINE FOR DEFENSE
PERSONNEL TO HAVE STRONG
POLITICAL VIEWS THAT ARE
CONSERVATIVE, BUT IN PRACTICE WE
ALREADY KNOW HOW THIS IS GOING
TO PLAY OUT.
LOOK AT HOW FAST OF THE
NATIONAL GUARD MOVED AGAINST ITS
OWN RANK AFTER THE CAPITOL
RIOTS.
APPARENTLY VETTING MORE THAN
25,000 NATIONAL GUARDSMEN
REMOVING ONE DOZEN OR SO FROM
INAUGURAL DUTY, ON DUBIOUS
GROUNDS BY THE WAY.
POSTING ON FACEBOOK I DO KNOW
STANDING FOR THE NATIONAL ANTHEM
AND FOOTBALL GAMES AND THE NEXT
THING YOU KNOW YOU COULD BE
LABELED A WHITE NATIONALIST.
TEXT A FRIEND ABOUT HOW YOU
THINK TRUMP IS GOOD FOR THE
FORGOTTEN MAN AND WOMAN.
YOU’RE PRACTICALLY A KKK MEMBER.
IF DEMOCRATS WERE CONCERNED
ABOUT STAMPING OUT EXTREMISM,
THEY’D BE LOOKING IN THE MIRROR.
HOW MANY WACKY, INCENDIARY,
INFLAMMATORY, DEFAMATORY HATEFUL
THINGS HAVE BEEN SAID BY THEIR
MEMBERS OVER THE PAST FIVE
YEARS?
JUST OVER THE PAST MONTH.
WE SHOULD DEVOTE AN ENTIRE SHOW
JUST TO LEFT WING EXTREMISM,
WHICH RUNS THE GAMUT FROM NT
4.0, BLM, OPEN BORDERS WHO THINK
WERE ALL LIVING ON STOLEN LAND.
WE ARE BIDEN AND FRIENDS WHEN
ISLAMIC RADICALS INFILTRATED THE
MILITARY RANKS DURING THE WAR ON
TERRORISM?
THANKFULLY, THEY WERE REPORTED
BUT MANY INNOCENT AMERICANS WERE
ALSO KILLED.
>> KILLED A U.S. ARMY RECRUITER
IN ARKANSAS.
TO SPEAK OF THE ARMY PRIVATE
ARRESTED WITH A CHARGE OF
ALLEGEDLY PLANNING ATTACK.
HE WAS ARRESTED AT A MOTEL IN
COLIMA TEXAS.
>> MUSLIM-AMERICAN, HE OPENED
FIRED AT TWO MILITARY CENTERS
KILLING FOUR MARINES.
>> THE FBI IS INVESTIGATING THE
SHOOTING AS AN ACT OF TERROR.
THE GUNMAN TIED TO SAUDI ARABIA.
>> Laura: SOMETIMES WE FORGET
THAT ALL OF THIS HAPPEN.
WHERE WERE THE CALLS FOR THE
IMMEDIATE VETTING OF ALL TROOPS
WITH CONNECTIONS TO ISLAMIC
EXTREMIST GROUPS?
I WAS DOING THIS ON RADIO EVERY
DAY DURING MOST OF THIS TIME
PERIOD, AND NOT ONLY DID THE
DEMOCRATS NOT DEMAND THAT TYPE
OF VETTING, THE ACCUSED US OF
ISLAMOPHOBIA FOR RAISING
CONCERNS.
>> RACIALLY PROFILING
PREDOMINATELY MUSLIM
NEIGHBORHOODS IS WRONG,
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE, DANGEROUS.
>> RIPPLED GUN HOPEFULS NEED TO
COME OUT AND BE AGAINST THIS
KIND OF ISLAMOPHOBIA.
>> IT’S OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO
REJECT PROPOSALS MOST OF
AMERICANS SHOULD BE TREATED
DIFFERENTLY.
>> Laura: WILD, DIVERSITY
UNLESS IT MEANS RESPECTING THE
APPEARANCE AND BELIEFS OF
CONSERVATIVES AND DEVOUT
CHRISTIANS AND OTHER RELIGIOUS
DENOMINATIONS.
INSTEAD OF LECTURING US ABOUT
THE IMPORTANCE OF TOLERANCE LIKE
THEY DID BACK THEN, LEFTISTS ARE
GLEEFULLY CALLING FOR A
IDEOLOGICAL CLEANSING OF THE
RANKS.
>> WHAT DO YOU MAKE ABOUT THIS
LINE OF MILITARY SERVICE AND
WHITE SUPREMACY?
>> THE GUARD IS 90 SOME ODD
PERCENT I BELIEVE MALE.
ONLY ABOUT 20% WHITE MALES WHO
VOTED FOR BIDEN.
>> WHO CAN’T PLEDGE A ALLEGIANCE
TO THEIR NATION, PULLED BY OTHER
VIEWS, NEED TO BE REMOVED BY THE
GUARD.
>> SAFETY HAS TO BE THE FIRST
PRIORITY.
>> Laura: SAFETY FOR HOME?
AND CERTAINLY IT’S NOT GOING TO
MAKE AMERICANS SAFER HAVING
AMERICANS TURN INTO THE ARM OF
THE DMCA.
WHAT ABOUT MILITARY MEMBERS OF
FAITH?
ALL, THEY’RE ALL MEN.
WHITE MEN.
IF YOU’RE A WHITE MALE,
CHRISTIAN, MAYBE YOU VOTED
REPUBLICAN, MAYBE LIKE TRUMP,
YOU’RE IMMEDIATELY SUSPICIOUS
AND THE SUSPECT.
HOW ARE ANY OF THOSE PEOPLE
SUPPOSED TO FEEL SAFER NOW?
OF COURSE ARE NOT GOING TO FEEL
SAFE.
SO, WHAT’S THE REAL GOAL HERE?
PREVENTING ANY IN THE COUNTRY
WHEN THE POLICY CERTAINLY AND
SLOWLY APPRISING US OF LIBERTY
AND PROSPERITY?
WELL, DID THE DEMOCRATS PLAN FOR
MORE CORONAVIRUS MUTATIONS?
ARE THEY WORRIED THAT MEMBERS OF
THE MILITARY ARE GOING TO SIDE
WITH THE CONSTITUTION?
INSTEAD OF CRAZY SOCIAL JUSTICE
WARRIORS WHO WANT TO REMAKE
AMERICA AND EVEN REMAKE THE
MILITARY?
FINALLY, MESSAGE TO THE
REPUBLICANS LIKE LIZ CHENEY.
THIS IS YOUR OPPORTUNITY TO SHOW
EVERYONE THAT YOU WILL FIGHT
HARDER AGAINST THE DEMOCRATS
THEN YOU DO AGAINST DONALD TRUMP
DONALD TRUMP.
REFUSE TO ALLOW A SINGLE U.S.
TAXPAYER DOLLARS TO FUND THIS
IDEOLOGICAL AND UN-AMERICAN
PURGE OF THE U.S. MILITARY.
OR EXPECT A LOT OF US TO PUSH
FOR DEEP CUTS.
WHY SHOULD WE FIND A
ORGANIZATION THAT THE DEMOCRATS
PLAN TO USE NOT TO PROTECT US,
BUT TO RESTRAIN US?